4 cuéntenos porque esta Cumbre es
recibida como histórica porque es
percibida como histórica
Buenas tardes Andrés Muchas gracias
Bueno esta Cumbre para empezar como bien
decías lleva ocho años sin celebrarse la
última que tuvimos
sucedió en en 2015 y es verdad que
durante estos últimos años especialmente
Los dos últimos años desde la crisis
relación derivada de la acogida a
abrahim Magali en 2021 pues se han
sucedido diversos episodios de tensión
entre los entre ambos países no
el último año ha estado protagonizado
por grandes esfuerzos del gobierno en
recauzar un poco estas relaciones con el
con el reino marroquí y se espera que
bueno pues que esta Cumbre sea como el
culmen de esta de extensión no de las
relaciones entre ambos no que se pueda
firmar Por fin una tregua entre ambos
países a propósito de esto que usted
acaba de mencionar marcará realmente
recubre un punto de inflexión en las
relaciones bilaterales servirá para
superar esas crisis
bueno Es verdad que nuestra historia
reciente hemos tenido crisis
periódicamente desafortunadamente con
con Marruecos pero sí que se espera que
sea un acuerdo importante el importe
económico previsto es del doble del que
del que se disfrutó en 2008 por lo que
la importancia sí que es sí que es de
relevancia Y tenemos sobre la mesa
desafíos conjuntos muy importantes para
los dos países así que bueno sí que sí
que debería ser no sé si la más
importante pero desde luego sí relevante
ahora señora históricamente cómo se han
beneficiado mutuamente estos dos países
de sus relaciones
bueno las ambos países tenemos
oportunidades y amenazas y desafíos
conjuntos entre los que se encuentra la
inmigración sin la cooperación de
Marruecos
de nuestros problemas de inmigración
ilegal y de crimen organizado serían
mucho mayores la cooperación marroquí es
fundamental en este aspecto
tenemos por supuesto La amenaza del
terrorismo
pudimos ver la semana pasada como
sufrimos un atentado terrorista
precisamente perpetrado por un ciudadano
marroquí estaba en situación ilegal en
territorio español pero luego tenemos
oportunidades tan importantes como son
en el sector de la energético o el
Industrial entonces
bueno Es verdad que nos encontramos en
uno de los momentos mejores momentos
diplomáticos con Marruecos al menos de
los últimos tiempos que deberíamos
aprovechar no y que las relaciones con
con las empresas
españolas y marroquíes pues deberían
deberían aprovechar hay otro punto muy
importante que son las ciudades
autónomas de ceuta y melilla que están
ambas Son son españolas y están en el
continente africano y uno de los grandes
acuerdos que se pretende conseguir
veremos si mañana finalmente es posible
o no es la apertura de de aduanas
comerciales en ambas ciudades No ya que
estas ciudades al estar aisladas
territorialmente de la Península son muy
dependientes de la economía marroquímica
de todos estos temas que usted mencionó
a su juicio Cuál es el que necesita ser
atendido con mayor urgencia
bueno actualmente tenemos el tema de la
seguridad el tema de la seguridad es
fundamental creo que abarcaría tanto
terrorismo como inmigración y este tipo
de redes de criminal de criminales
organizados y
la energía no que a nivel regional y
teniendo en cuenta las problemáticas que
está que está teniendo también el
gobierno español con con Argelia y el
gobierno marroquí Pues en el tema
energético también Tendremos que abordar
avances importantes